all right here's an update on big booty  gate um  see this guy right there  right there  he when i was walking up  um  he said hey  right in front of a capitol police  officer see my favorite big booty latina  i love you aoc you're my favorite hey  uh  here's this look at that big ass look at  that big juicy booty this latina like  whatever she adds additional  descriptions of her booty that were  never actually used so she said she  claims that her booty was described as  as juicy we need to snope fact check on  that because that was never said like  that's how she's describing herself and  then putting that in the words in the  into the mouth of uh  well that's unfortunate phrasing that  that's how she's choosing to describe  herself this is a  another juicy sommelier she's putting  the juicy and juicy here i suppose  justice for juicy